Let's go next to our caller from the nine
five six area code. Who's calling today from
nine five six.
This is rocky. Raina from the rocky Rainer
show.
Hi Rocky. What's going on?
Um, I want to point out two different things.
First of all, I'm a big fan. I watch your
show. I'm also a small utuber and I first
things first, one thing I know I'm a conservative,
I'm a native American conservative, um, who
has his own show. But I noticed that your
Kryptonite is Donald Trump. Does that make
sense?
No, it doesn't. What do you mean my Kryptonite?
I think that you're a pretty level headed
person as a conservative. There's a lot of
things that I would have very difficulty disagreeing
with you, except when it comes to Donald Trump,
I think that he clouds your judgment because
he's arrogant.
So what's an example of that?
Um, I see like, you know how you put out various
videos on youtube, they're like four or five
minutes.
Yes. We published videos to youtube. Yeah.
Okay. You tend to nitpick on little insignificant
things that I know add up. But in the broader,
or for example, when you were on Jesse Lee
Peterson show, he asked you a question. You,
it's not that you didn't answer. He just basically
said, well, you don't like Trump and I can
tell you he really got a rise out of you.
What did I say? How did you get a rise out
of me?
[inaudible]
um, you said, no, that's not true. You're
not letting me speak. And then he kicked you
off the show. But before he did that is basically,
um, you couldn't, he asks you what are the
good things that he did, what are some of
the good things that he did? And then he said,
um,
well I know with them. Yeah, I remember I
listed, I listed the things. Yeah.
Okay. But for example, for border security
though would, I mean to me that's a pretty
rational. What, what's your objections to
that? I mean, I don't know if you have any
listeners that live on the border. It's fairly
dangerous.
What's my objection to what,
um, like on the wall,
the wall's a waste of money and it doesn't
actually deal with the reason people are trying
to come here nor visa overstays which are
a bigger problem than people crossing the
wall physically.
Okay. And so, okay. For example, another thing
I know, I don't want to be disrespectful,
but you're, you're Argentinian, correct?
I'm sorry, I'm Wa I'm Argentinian. Yes, yes
I am.
Okay. Now you, would you say you come from
like a middle class background or an upper
middle class background?
No, my family left Argentina cause we had
no money in the economy imploded. So we came
to the u s with nothing. And then my dad,
um, he had to go back through, you know, he
was a doctor in Argentina, which sounds luxurious
but it's not trust me. Uh, doctors in Argentina
in 1989 were not making any money. He had
to reestablish himself as a doctor here in
the U S and I guess like 10 or 12 years after
we were here, he finally started making you
know, a a good salary. But no, I mean our
first 10 years here in the U s we're not particularly
easy.
It's, I guess the point that I'm trying to
make is that it just seems that the majority
of social media personalities on Youtube or
just in general, they come from a very middle
class, upper middle class background.
What would be an eight? So I didn't come from
that. But who are you thinking of?
Well, for example, I'm no disrespect you,
Sam Cedar.
No, but we just figured out that that's not
the case. My family left Argentina with no
money. And so that, so we figured out. That
doesn't apply to me. I don't know about some
of this background.
I mean, have you ever lived in a dangerous
neighborhood? You hear gunshots at night,
did you? I mean, I live in, I live, I live
in Massachusetts, so Massachusetts as a state
is, there's very few parts of Massachusetts
where you're hearing gunshots at night. I
just don't know what point you're trying to
make.
Oh, well I'm trying to make, is that a lot
of progressive's that I see? They don't really
have, I mean, they want something, but they've
never, they, they're advocating for people
that come from a struggle and, and I think
when you overcome adversity by yourself on
your own, you look at things a lot differently.
But isn't that empathy? Like, isn't that,
isn't that good? Don't we want people who
can say, hey, even if I don't need something
myself, this is still a good thing for the
government to do because I'm thinking about
other people. Like that's called empathy.
That seems like a good thing.
Well, I mean, yeah, it's thousand 19 in empathy
and to get anything accomplished with all
due respect, what gets things accomplished
is hard work. I mean, a strong work ethic
and logic. And we know when it comes to John
t logical person in the world. But when you
would disagree with me that he'd gotten a
lot done, whether good or bad.
No. What do all the assays. Yes. He's gotten
a lot done. If you say good or bad, he's gotten
a lot done. That's bad. I agree with that.
Well, I mean he's, well, I mean that's what
I'm saying. He's ruffled a lot of feathers
and,
but is that a good thing? What's the best
thing Trump's done? Rocky, what's the best
thing Trump's done?
Um, well, the woman he got into, I'm a veteran.
So when got into office, one of the first
things that he did was, didn't he, um, give
veterans more money for disability?
I Dunno. You tell me. Is that what he did?
When did he do that?
Yeah, yeah, he did. He did. And then he did
again recently. He's also took money that
was allocated for, uh, for military and he,
he just did that recently and putting it into
border security or I listened to the,
yeah, it's unclear whether that's even legal.
All right rocky. Listen, I guess you've made
a number of different points and I appreciate
you calling in. Okay.
Okay. Can you do me one, one favor? Cause
like I said, I have my own youtube channel
and even though I'm a conservative, I'm a
die hard fan. I watch your show. Can you just
say, um, cause I have you on my microphone.
Can you say thank you for watching the rocky
or say, um,
no. Listen, I can't do that cause I have no
idea anything about your show or what it is
that I would be endorsing. So that's not something
I can do today.
Oh Man. All right, well hopefully I'll come
out on the youtube channel if you watch my
show. I don't, I'm not like one of those alt-right,
bum satirical silver. All right.
All right, good. Very good. Rocky, thank you
so much for the call. I very much appreciate
it.